when you wear the rings of power you win
or you die
wait that's not right game of thrones
and lord of the rings are two different
shows still they hold a surprising
connection while the entire genre of
fantasy fiction owes a huge debt to j.r
tolkien the creation of amazon's first
foray into middle-earth the lord of the
rings the rings of power might be a
byproduct of the success of game of
thrones hbo's adaptation of george rr
martin's a song of ice and fire book
series was the ultimate fantasy saga of
the 2010s inspiring networks and
streaming services to acquire the rights
to popular genre ips without game of
thrones shows such as the witcher and
the wheel of time might not exist of
course comparisons between the
aforementioned franchises were always
inevitable considering that amazon's the
rings of power debuted shortly after the
premiere of house of the dragon on hbo
even martin knows that viewers will pit
the shows against each other in a battle
of fantasy warfare but he hopes that
people can enjoy both shows on their own
accord he told the independent i hope
both shows succeed i'm competitive
enough i hope we succeed more if they
win six emmys and i hope they do i hope
we win seven at the end of the day the
lord of the rings and game of thrones
franchises are unique entities that
bring their own spins to fantasy fair
however that doesn't mean they don't
share some common elements that enable
perfectly understandable comparisons to
be made robert armaio is the force that
binds together the rings of power and
game of thrones franchises the 29 year
old english actor has developed a knack
for playing popular characters on
fantasy series or to be more specific
playing the younger versions of beloved
established characters aromaio rose to
fame by portraying a young ned stark
during the sixth season of game of
thrones he appeared in a series of
flashback sequences that shed some light
on jon snow's family history no
now it ends he did an admirable job of
honoring the legacy of sean bean who
played the house of stark leader during
his middle aged years of course one does
not simply forget that sean bean
connected the lord of the rings and game
of thrones when it premiered in 2011. so
ned stark is the true connector between
george rr martin and j.r tolkien in the
rings of power the englishman plays a
younger version of elrond the legendary
half elven character who's appeared in
every on-screen lord of the rings
project to date the character who was
brought to life by hugo weaving in lord
of the rings and the hobbit will have a
key role to play in the amazon series
which was what attracted armaio to the
fantasy project in the first place the
elrond we meet in the lord of the rings
the rings of power is slightly different
from the wise and storied warrior we see
in peter jackson's movies here he's not
quite the strong stubborn commanding
leader that he went on to become for a
start he's relatively uninterested in
attending council meetings and
concerning himself with political
matters additionally he's not on the
best terms with some of the elves allies
though he is able to use his charm and
cunning to get what he wants during
moments of political persuasion while
speaking to variety robert aramaio
revealed that bringing young elrond to
fruition was exciting as it meant
exploring unchartered territory in some
ways furthermore he doesn't think that
game of thrones and the rings of power
are anything alike with the exception of
being fantasy series that he worked on
he said they're very very different
shows my job on game of thrones and my
job on the rings of power were very
different according to the actor game of
thrones allowed him to draw upon
material that was already there for
inspiration however since the first and
second ages of middle earth are open to
interpretation in many ways the rings of
power allowed him to essentially build a
character from scratch
[Music]